[Musique]
écoutez ce qu'on attend depuis très
longtemps c'est eux la réconciliation
entre les deux peuples le peuple
français le peuple algérien qui
d'ailleurs n'ont jamais été en brouille
et les peuples c'est une affaire
politique cette affaire est donc je
dirais grâce à cette initiative ce que
nous attendons mais faut voir ce qu'il
ya dedans dans ce rapport voir plus loin
moi j'ai vu quelques extraits et donc de
créer des conditions de la réussite de
deux bonnes relations entre les deux
peuples l'économie culturelle en fait il
faut regarder l'avenir c'est à dire que
si on travaille bien le passé nous
allons voir l'avenir et l'avenir des
enfants de ce pays
ce que j'appelle moi les français
héritiers de l'immigration algérienne
est aussi l'ensemble des français
puisque cette histoire concerne la
france c'est l'histoire de france et
c'est l'histoire de l'algérie
en même temps je ne pense pas qu'ils
aient aujourd'hui de conflit
effectivement entre les peuples al jalae
peuple français mais il peut y avoir du
conflit avec l'état algérien qui parfois
se montre un petit peu belliqueux et
exige une repentance que nous n'avons
pas donné puisque ce la repentance n'est
pas quelque chose en fait qui permet
d'avancer un reconnaître effectivement
ce qui s'est passé durant la
colonisation en algérie et durant la
guerre d'algérie
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire et
il faut que trop récente ce soit à
double sens
c'est à dire qu'il faut aussi qu'ils
reconnaissance de la part de l'état
algérien actuel de ce qu'elle a pu de ce
qu'il a pu faire de ce qu'il a pu se
passer pendant la guerre d'algérie
notamment vis-à-vis des pieds-noirs et
nous français sommes prêt évidemment à
reconnaître qu'il ya eu de notre part
durant la certains épisodes de la
colonisation des excès évidemment mais
pas que
dans la france n'a pas à se repentir
manuel macro avait commis cette erreur
en 2016 comme il y avait parlé d'un
crime contre l'humanité visiblement il
revient en arrière puisque benjamin
stora qui est un grand historien la
faire revenir à la raison
il a expliqué que la repentance c'était
une attitude qui ne pouvait créer que du
malheur on peut imaginer par exemple des
co productions de séries télévisées de
film franco algérienne axées tard mais
ça doit pas partir de l'état français et
algériens savent à partir d'initiatives
d'intellectuels d'écrivains
je pense que ce serait une erreur de le
confier à l'état assure à nos deux états
la charge de cette mémoire qui est déjà
lourde la reconnaissance n'est pas la
repentance nous on réclame c'est là haut
la reconnaissance et la reconnaissance
par les plus hautes autorités de l'état
c'est important la reconnaissance de
bois la reconnaissance bas d'un crime à
ce qu' il faut rappeler quand même parce
qu'on a tendance à oublier que
l'histoire coloniale a été une histoire
filiale anton des années 1830 on se
rappeler de ce qu'a dit le général
bugeaud à l'époque en 1830 et dit tuez
les tous qui n'en reste pas un seul ça a
été violent ça a été une expropriation
ça a été quelque chose de terrible de
vraiment où les populations ont beaucoup
souffert
on souhaite c'est aussi et que ce soit
inscrit dans les manuels d'histoire dans
l'est dans les livres d'histoire et que
parce que beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
français les camarades français que avec
lesquels on a été tout petits à l'école
ne connaissent pas l'histoire
c'est-à-dire leur histoire c'est à dire
notre histoire commune et ceci est
injuste et donc c'est quelque chose de
très important enfin l'histoire le lien
est là est là elle a enrichi la france
il faut pas l'oublier
la france il est devenu une puissance
importante aujourd'hui c'est le produit
de quand même deux cent quarante deux
ans de colonialisme et aussi de
d'extraction d'un certain nombre de
richesses etc
donc il est normal aujourd'hui qu'une
coopération vial pour qu'il y ait en
quelque sorte une sorte de préparation
de l'algérie et des algériens en tout
cas et ça ça passe par eux évidemment
des la coopération entre les deux pays
et donc de manière sereine et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut travailler ensemble et
travailler ensemble par aussi ceux qui
travaillent sur le terrain et je
conseille aussi aux indes de sortir un
petit peu de ça et aux politiques elle
vient d'arrêter d'utiliser cette
histoire dès qu'il ya un problème chez
heures en fait comme diversion parce que
c'est ce qu'au fond c'est ce qu'a fait
bouteflika pendant des années quand même
c'est une diversion la guerre d'algérie
pour prévu pour éluder les véritables
problèmes c'est à dire le le chômage
massif de la jeunesse algérienne
le manque de libertés individuelles et
de liberticide c'est dommage parce que
l'algérie par exemple si on le compare
avec d'autres pays du maghreb c'est un
pays il ya de très grands écrivains où
il ya une vie culturelle qui est riche
il ya des choses extrêmement
intéressante
il ya une vieille une forme de liberté
laïque aussi en algérie qui n'existaient
pas forcément ailleurs
c'est une véritable sas et ça aurait pu
être une vraie république
inspiré de la france ils ont gardé
certains éléments aussi 2 du code
napoléonien
y avait il ya du potentiel il ya
toujours moi je crois toujours engagé
mais je pense que si on continue à
demander à la france à des réparations
de reconnaître des crimes et tout ça ça
ne marchera pas